das auto bitte komplett frei kratzen für
freie sicht sorgen wenn das auto dann
anspringt und die batterie eben nicht
schlag gemacht hat oder der diesel
eingefroren ist wie wir eben gehört
haben dann bitte ganz vorsichtig und
langsam fahren darauf einstellen dass es
länger dauert
am besten ist man hat auch in heißen tee
oder in heißen kaffee dabei falls man
doch mal irgendwo stecken bleibt und
ansonsten wirklich zeit nehmen wirklich
einfach zeit nehmen ganz langsam machen
gucken wenn die räumfahrzeuge unterwegs
sind dass man sich am besten hinter den
reid und nicht versucht vor den noch
wegzufahren
am besten immer darauf achten dass die
straße einigermaßen frei ist dann
klappt's auch haben sie denn auch noch
tipps wie ich mein auto wir haben vorhin
auch bilder aus münster gesehen da sind
die autos teilweise wir völlig
verschluckt vom schnee gibt es
irgendwelche geheimen tricks wie man
diese wieder frei kriegt und haben sie
vielleicht auch noch ein tipp wenn ich
mich auf den straßen befinden sondern
auf die autobahn auffahren immerhin gilt
die ja oft als geräumt oder ist es bei
so einem wetter vielleicht fast besser
in ruhe ein paar umwege zu fahren wo
vielleicht weniger verkehr ist also zum
ersten punkt zudem frei räumen da ist es
sehr schwer einen tipp zu geben da geht
es eigentlich wirklich darum am besten
wenn man hilfe aus der nachbarschaft hat
und alle schippen gemeinsam
dann geht es am schnellsten ansonsten
hatten wir eben von den kollegen auch
gehört den türschloss enteiser wenn man
so einen hat dann nicht im auto liegen
lassen dass es auch meistens wirklich
sehr hilfreich ansonsten hilft wirklich
nur schippen schippen schippen gerade in
solchen städten wie münster wo das
wirklich so dramatisch aussieht im
moment
und dann wirklich das auto auch einen
moment lang warm laufen lassen nicht die
klimaanlage und die heizung sofort voll
aufdrehen sondern langsam kommen lassen
stück für stück von 1 auf 2 834 die
lüftung drehen und die heizung langsam
kommen lassen dass die scheiben nicht
sofort diese wucht an heißer luft
abkriegen dass es nämlich auch sehr
schlecht dann können die im schlimmsten
fall nämlich sogar platzen
ansonsten kann man eigentlich nur sagen
wirklich nach wie vor vorsichtig fahren
und vorsichtig unterwegs sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren